you
we have everything we need to survive
air to breathe and food and water to
sustain life it's incredible the effort
that was needed to design this life
support system flying around the planet
aboard the International Space Station
approve astronauts from around
so wonders of
as a few can
unique vantage we gain insight into the
impact we have on the environment and
witness what humankind can accomplish
when we work together
the arrival to the space station was
possibly the happiest move to my life
looking at Earth from space we need to
start to consider some s'mores remember
not passengers hello it's nice to meet
you
best part about being an astronaut is
looking back at our home planet
especially at night the cities are so
bright and so vibrant and so colorful
this is just overwhelmingly beautiful
I'm in cooperation with NASA and vice
or the International Space Station
or an incredible care it's a giant
universe out there there's lots of stars
lots of planets but there's nowhere like
Orion to explore the challenges we face
and the changes we can make to secure
our future in the end it's about
understanding how the natural world
works and that is about expanding
possibilities of what we human beings
can do
a beautiful plan the voyage begins
exclusively and IMAX and IMAX 3d
theaters
you